Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
Who wants to jump on board
this groovy train with us?
John:
That is the money shot.
Your money ‐‐
we need it, lots of it.
You scare
the crap out of me.
[ Both laugh ]
I'm talking about investment
in our fathers and our children.
What could be better than that?
I went online, tried to see
if there was a patent out there.
When it came back, I thought,
"Okay, we need to go for this."
You will never work for anybody
for the rest of your life.
Wow.
You sold your homes
to start this business.
‐Ooh!
‐It's okay.
Narrator: And later,
the Sharks give advice
on how to cope
with the financial fallout
of the coronavirus pandemic.
Greiner:
People are losing their jobs.
People are worried about
what their futures will bring.
Cuban: There are so many places
you can turn to
for loans and grants.
There's no end to
entrepreneurship in America.
Right now,
the next giant company is
being invented
in somebody's basement.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is an accessory line
that is durable and stylish.
♪♪
What is up,
everybody?!
[ Chuckles ]
I'm Skylar Bennett.
And I'm Kevin Shoemaker.
We're from the beautiful
Mesa, Arizona,
and we're the creators
of the Tough Tie.
But more
on that later.
But first, your money ‐‐
we need it, lots of it.
We're asking for $100,000 in
exchange for 15% of our company.
Let's be real, Sharks.
Life is messy!
But life with kids...
...is a tornado of filth!
[ Laughter ]
From spills and spit‐up
to tugging and smearing,
your clothes
take a beating!
Worse than a white shirt
at a tomato festival.
Both: #DadJokes.
[ Laughs ]
And that expensive tie
you're wearing
made with loose stitching
and fragile materials
is easily snagged,
and it has to be dry‐cleaned.
Both: #HighMaintenance.
But as they say...
[ Both grunt ]
...fatherhood is the mother
of invention.
Introducing...
♪ Ahh ♪
...Tough Ties.
Designed with
real‐life situations in mind
that give you
confidence!
What does that even mean?
Number one...
A 100% unique design
allowing it to be
regularly machine‐washed.
And yes, this has been washed
multiple, multiple times.
That looks awesome.
Thanks.
[ Whispering ]
I know.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Number two...
An iron‐lock stitch.
Our ties have five times
the stitching of a normal tie.
They are
never coming apart.
And number three...
This is our favorite.
Every single tie we make
is 100%
stain‐ and liquid‐repellant!
What?!
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Not to mention
the microfiber tipping
to clean your phone screen
or glasses.
[ Laughter ]
In a nutshell, Tough Ties
will endure life's mishaps,
allowing you
to always look your best.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to tie the knot with Tough Tie?
[ Chuckles ]
Great job.
Now our man‐baby ‐‐
You got some samples?
Man‐baby Logan's gonna hand out
some ties.
The man‐baby!
That's great.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughing ] Oh, yes!
But wait ‐‐
there's socks!
Thank you.
[ Chuckles ]
Oh, that's cute.
Custom, obviously.
‐Oh, yeah.
‐Thank you, sir.
‐Ooh! Hello.
‐I notice that Mr. Wonderful is
featured on this tie ‐‐
a very wise move.
‐I love the pattern.
‐Oh, yeah.
‐It's really cute.
‐So, all those ‐‐ Crazy thing.
All of those were designed
and printed
and manufactured
this week.
‐What?
‐Really?
So, part of the feature of this
is I can do customized ties
with images on them?
Absolutely.
So, we actually handle
the printing process in‐house.
So, it's called dye sublimation,
if you've heard of that.
Yes, we have.
So, we have
our own equipment in‐house,
so we control
the printing.
Kevin does a lot
of the design work,
so we can turn prints around
almost immediately.
We literally ‐‐
From design to production,
those Shark ties took
just a few days.
So, tell us the story.
You have your own machines.
You have a factory.
Yeah, what's the story
of you two? How long have
you guys been together?
Skylar and I ‐‐
we're both ‐‐
we're both young
working professionals.
We're both dads.
I've got three kids.
‐You're a dad?
‐I got three kids!
‐Three kids? How old are you?
‐Come on!
‐29.
‐Kevin, you're 29?!
Skylar's got
three kids.
‐And they're not triplets?
‐I'm 30.
Not triplets ‐‐
all born separately.
Yep.
So, we ‐‐ Our background is
commercial real estate.
We were just young hustlers
getting our career ready,
and tie ‐‐ shirt and tie ‐‐
that's part
of the uniform, right?
You have to look good.
You have to feel good.
You got to be the part.
What we realized very,
very quickly was that your ties
get destroyed immediately
from kids eating them
and spitting up on them.
From meeting at lunches,
you spill on your tie.
Dry cleaning
only kind of works.
And so we are trying
to solve that problem.
Are you still doing
commercial real estate?
No, we're not.
So, we left our full‐time ‐‐
This is a full‐time gig?
Correct. Over two years ago,
we left our jobs.
So, are you sustaining
six kids?
Over two years ago?
Over two years ago.
Over two years ago, yeah.
This business is sustaining
two families and six kids?
So, it's getting there.
The business is
profitable, okay?
[ Chuckles ]
We're not paying ourselves
as much as we should be yet.
We have very,
very supportive wives...
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐...who have given up a lot.
Yeah, they have three kids
with you.
I know!
[ Laughs ]
And are they working?
They work full time.
Both wives work full time.
What are your sales today?
So, to date, we're at lifetime
sales of $450,000.
What about last year,
this year?
Last year was
$208,000.
We've already hit $200,000
this year.
We're on track for $400,000
How are you selling it?
Primarily online,
through our website.
What is it gonna cost me?
What does it cost you to make?
Great question.
So, our high‐end tie,
which is
the Hustle Collection ‐‐
The yellow?
Shoemaker: Yeah,
with the white tags on them.
That is $45 retail.
$45?
Yep.
Oy!
What's the cost
to make it?
So, we make those in
our U. S. manufacturer for $15.
‐Fully loaded?
‐Yes, $15 out the door.
Herjavec: Skylar,
walk us through the numbers.
What will you do this year?
We're gonna do over $400,000
this year in sales.
At that $400,000...
Yep.
...will you make money?
Yes.
Where's the major‐‐
How much will you make?
So, we should make
roughly $40,000 in profit
on that $400,000.
Why so low?
Where's all the money going?
Right now, we're paying
for our customers, right?
Meaning?
We are just doing
paid advertising online.
We spend roughly $10,000 a month
on paid advertising.
The reason we do that is
'cause we get a 200% return.
How much of your money
is invested,
and do you have any debt?
Yeah, we started out ‐‐
we both put in
about $43,000
of our own money...
That's combined.
...just savings,
everything like that,
to get it off the ground.
We've got about
$150,000 of debt right now.
And who
did you borrow from?
So, we sold
our houses.
Whoa!
You sold your homes
to start this business?
Both of us.
This isn't just
a start‐up for us.
This is who we are.
It's what we believe in.
The challenge
you have today is,
you're young, you're cool,
you're hip,
but the macro trend is,
guys aren't wearing ties.
I'm glad you brought that up.
And we see it, right?
We're not naive to that.
We 100% see that.
But, again, the goal here is
to build this
into more than just
a tie company.
To what?
So, what else are you thinking
of doing besides socks?
So, the name of the company is
actually Tough Apparel.
Tough Tie is
our staple product.
Currently, we do ties,
belts, and socks,
is our current
product lineup.
Look, to me, building a brand is
about execution.
Sure.
It's about
a great product.
And here you guys
come walking in,
and I get what
you're trying to accomplish,
but there's a lot
of polyester ties out there.
Maybe yours is just better,
better, better,
but it's not obvious
from looking at it.
Sure.
I just don't see the vision
coming to fruition.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you, Mark.
We appreciate it.
I'm kind of on the fence with
this thing 'cause, normally,
I wouldn't want to go in that
business, but, you know,
listen, I did the deal
with the Bombas socks guys,
and I said, "Eh,
this is never gonna work."
I couldn't be more
wrong or inaccurate.
Because they kind of
remind me of you.
You kind of know your target,
and, you know,
you're positioning it
in a different way.
But in that deal, you know,
it was really appealing
to so many different people
for so many reasons ‐‐
females, males,
and everybody still needs
to wear socks
most of the time.
Sure.
I just think this is just
too tight of a segment for me.
I'm just ‐‐ I'm out.
Okay. Thank you, Daymond.
We appreciate it.
Skylar, every time you say
the word "brand,"
you scare
the crap out of me.
I just want you to sell
a lot of ties.
Okay.
Best way to build a brand ‐‐
build a successful business.
Absolutely.
Yep.
I think you're both
quite brilliant.
You're extremely enjoyable.
Like, I don't think
I could adore you more.
[ Both laugh ]
I'm 100% in on you guys.
I'm just not 100% in
on the tie business.
So, unfortunately,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you, Lori.
We appreciate it.
I'm a little
more pragmatic.
How many units of ties?
How many units you sell?
Units of ties?
Yeah. Just total, you think,
just units?
Next year,
we expect to sell
between 10,000
and 13,000 units of ties.
If you do 13,000 units a year
and you're growing at,
let's say, 20%,
it's gonna take me seven years,
if I even put a royalty
of a buck a tie on it,
to get my capital back.
That's the only way
I'd do it.
I still have to wait
seven years.
It's like
[vocalizing dirge]
[ Laughter ]
That was good.
[ Laughter continues ]
My thing is,
I was gonna take less equity
with some path
to getting liquidity sooner.
Sure.
Robert is "build the company,"
and I appreciate that.
Plus, he's got guys
in the space,
which is
extremely helpful.
I'm gonna make this
a binary decision for you.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
Well...
Let me tell you ‐‐
you guys are great.
I mean, it's a really, really
fun vibe you have about you.
It's super fun.
I love the humor.
So I'm gonna
make you an offer.
♪♪
Narrator: Four Sharks are out,
but Robert is interested
in Kevin and Skylar's
durable‐accessories company,
Tough Tie.
Let me tell you ‐‐
you guys are great.
I mean, it's a really, really
fun vibe you have about you.
It's super fun.
I love the humor.
So I'm gonna
make you an offer.
$100,000 for 35%.
Ooh!
You got to really love
those guys.
We're gonna pair you
with Buttercloth.
We'll do over $3.5 million
this year.
When they came on the show
a year ago...
Right.
...I think they were doing
$100,000.
Can we just talk
for two seconds?
Two seconds ‐‐ right here!
Don't go anywhere.
[ Both whispering ]
We would love you
as a partner.
Thank you.
And we will grind,
like ‐‐
and will continue
to grind like crazy.
I expect you to.
We would like
to counteroffer
$100,000 for 25%
of the company.
No.
$100,000 for 35%.
‐Wow. Wow.
‐Ruh‐roh!
That's a lot
of polyester.
[ Chuckles ]
But you know what you can do
with polyester?
You can stretch it!
We're gonna
stretch that money,
and we're gonna build
a big business.
I'm the only one that saw
the vision in you guys.
$100,000, 35%.
Let's do it.
Would you be willing
to do 1/3, 1/3, 1/3?
We're all equal partners.
Let's build this thing together.
Let's crush it.
That's not unreasonable.
Really?
You're gonna nickel‐and‐dime me
for the other couple percent?
No. $100,000 for 35%.
Wow. Robert.
Greiner: Robert!
Robert, come on.
What are you doing, Robert?
33 1/3%.
That's a point and a half.
Point and a half.
Six kids! Six kids.
[ Laughs ]
Wow. That ‐‐
John: Come on, Robert.
$100,000, 35%.
I know
the work it takes
and the pain and the sweat
and all the other stuff.
I'm not trying
to sell you on it.
It's the offer
I think is good for me,
and I think
it's a good offer for you.
$100,000, 35%.
What are you gonna do?
Okay.
You got an offer, baby.
Let's do it!
[ Cheering ]
I didn't see that
coming.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God!
I'm really glad!
Okay. Thank you, guys.
Appreciate it.
Thanks, guys.
We'll see you.
Thank you so much.
Whoo!
Whoo‐hoo!
Hyuh!
Ahh!
Shoemaker: It was literally
a tank of Sharks.
Like, it's no joke
naming it "Shark Tank."
It was crazy!
But if Tough Ties
can survive babies spitting
and pulling
and tugging,
then Tough Ties
can survive the Tank.
♪♪
This is a message to America.
To our "Shark Tank" fans.
To our entrepreneurs.
To our small‐business owners.
To all of the helpers
out there.
The entire world is facing
something we've never seen
in our lifetime.
Greiner:
People are losing their jobs,
and people are worried about
what their futures will bring.
Herjavec: Whether you're
a small‐business owner
or just trying to help
your family,
we're here with some advice.
Corcoran:
The moment you think
you won't be able
to pay this month's rent,
you've got to
call the landlord immediately.
And be reasonable.
Offer something.
But ask for his help on letting
you waylay some of your costs
for a time later to catch up.
There are so many places you can
turn to for loans and grants.
Go to your state's
government website.
Go to your city's
Don't be ashamed.
It's an opportunity
to save your business
and maybe even propel it
into something bigger and better
than it was before.
In the bad times like this,
you've got to be
brutally transparent
and honest with your team.
There might be some layoffs.
You may have to cut
certain costs.
Your team needs to know
what's going on.
If you're worried about your
investments, remember this ‐‐
we went into
this global pandemic
with the best economy
we've had in decades.
These are gonna be
very volatile markets,
but there's one thing
we've learned
from this kind of volatility
in the past ‐‐
you can't time the market.
Don't look at these times
as a setback.
Look at them as an opportunity.
Start to improve
your social‐media presence.
Improve your website.
Do the things that you never had
time to do before.
Get active.
This is a true time
to reflect on your "why."
Why did you start a business?
Why are you working
where you're working?
Why are you trying
to change people's lives?
Now is the time that your "why"
is put to the test.
♪♪
Corcoran:
These are the times
that will make warriors
out of entrepreneurs.
It will show you
what you're made of.
And once you see this through,
you'll build the confidence
to know you can
get through anything.
There's no end to
entrepreneurship in America.
Right now,
the next giant company
is being invented
in somebody's basement.
John: There will always be
some challenge in the world,
but true entrepreneurs
and survivors know
how to adjust
and become stronger,
and that is what makes us
unstoppable.
When we come out of this,
know we will be more united
than ever.
Cuban: And when we get
to the other side,
when we get to America 2.0,
we can and will make it
a better place.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a fashion line
for self‐expression.
♪♪
Hello.
My name is Schuyler Ellers,
and I'm the creator
of one of the hottest
fashion trends on the Internet.
I'm seeking $100,000 in exchange
for 10% of my company.
Sharks, crochet takes us
back to a time
when life was simpler
and everything was groovy.
[ Chuckles ]
But most importantly,
crochet promotes positive vibes
and makes people happy.
And that's why
I created my company ‐‐
Lord Von Schmitt.
My crochet designs
are colorful, sustainable,
recycled, and repurposed.
But why take it from me, when
you can see for yourselves?
Hit it!
[ Up‐tempo music plays ]
Uriel and Deanna's outfits
are aligned
with a slow fashion movement
and come with two
fabulous accessories ‐‐
lower carbon footprints
and reduced waste.
Whoo!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Ana and Azuri are certain
to be the life of any party.
Crochet is addictive.
You might get hooked
on the attention.
[ Light laughter ]
John: There you go. That's
the money shot right there.
[ Laughter ]
That is the money shot!
Herjavec:
Daymond! That's you!
‐There you go, baby!
‐He takes his LEDs for a spin...
‐Oh! Ah!
‐...and the crowd goes wild.
‐That is nasty, nasty, nasty.
‐Yeah.
So, Sharks, who wants to jump on
board this groovy train with us?
[ Laughter ]
‐I love it.
‐Oh, my goodness.
I have some handouts
for you.
Daymond,
you should try it on.
Robert, I'm a little, uh, husky,
so I'd look like a piñata.
[ Laughter ]
You would, actually.
I would look like a piñata,
for sure.
Thank you so much.
‐This stuff is beautiful.
‐Thank you.
Cuban: I love a good crochet.
Thanks, Schuyler.
How's that look?
[ Laughter ]
What do you think,
Schuyler?
Oh! Beautiful!
[ Laughs ]
Mark, yours are
a little low‐waisted.
Know how to do
a booty shake, Robert?
How did you get
those pants on?
♪♪
I like them.
I'm in.
‐I can't wear those.
‐Let's do it.
Herjavec: I like it.
Cuban: Daymond's walking
the whole runway.
Shake it, baby.
[ Laughter ]
O'Leary:
Whoa! That's hot.
That is so hot.
[ Laughs ]
You actually look really good
in that, Daymond.
It is a good look
for you, Daymond.
‐Interesting.
‐Okay.
Well, thanks so much
for trying them on.
O'Leary: So, Schuyler, tell us
about how you got into this.
This looks like a handmade art,
in some ways.
This is a handmade art,
which I create.
entirely from
recycled crocheted blankets.
If you're making them by hand,
how can you produce in quantity?
Those are created
based on my crochet designs,
and they are created
in Asia.
You outsource it.
I outsource it.
So you have a factory
that's making them for you.
Yeah.
Schuyler, what
do you sell them for?
So, the things that have been
manufactured are these parasols.
And how much is
a parasol?
To get a parasol to
the United States costs me $30,
and I sell them for $128
on my website.
Wow!
O'Leary: So, you have to
get word out
so people know about this,
'cause we didn't know about this
on "Shark Tank" ‐‐ never heard
of Lord Von Schmitt.
So, Lord Von Schmitt started
as my own weird little project,
until suddenly it got picked up
on the Internet.
And all of those blogs
ultimately culminated
in a major publicity boom
that sold a ton of things.
And mostly,
it was men's shorts
made from recycled
Afghan blankets.
How much are
the short shorts?
Short shorts are $58.
And the entire suit?
What about the long ones
beside it?
And then, the entire suit,
I can get $300.
Wow.
You wearing those
right now?
As a matter of fact, I am.
‐Bang!
‐[ Laughs ]
Now, you seem like
you're definitely
a fascinating
and interesting person.
You have all our attention.
What's your background?
So, I studied visual arts
at Columbia University.
Nice.
I was an English teacher
for years,
and I lived in Barcelona.
So, from there, I got into
knitting and crochet ‐‐
just typical,
what everybody does.
[ Laughter ]
When I came back
from Barcelona,
I saw Afghan blankets
in the thrift store.
America has a ton of Afghans.
We have a glut of Afghans.
So I created these, and I put
them up on my Etsy shop.
Greiner: Yeah.
Okay.
And then I took
a little trip to India.
All of a sudden,
I saw this bizarre spike
in men's shorts,
which I hadn't sold
a ton of prior to that.
And by the time I had
300 open orders for shorts,
I had to leave India
and go back to the United States
to make them.
I went to thrift store
after thrift store ‐‐
Cut them up,
sewed them together.
Shorts.
How many orders did you get
on the shorts total?
Total? More than 300.
325.
Okay.
So, who's buying these?
Like, what is your demographic?
Me. Guys like me.
My demographic
is a lot of people
who go
to summer festivals.
There's a very large
LGBTQIA+ contingent
that follows this fashion.
Are you making any money today?
What are your sales?
My sales are $188,000.
‐Wow!
‐So far this year?
‐When did you start?
‐For four years.
For four years?
Yes.
What about last year?
Last year was $37,000.
Okay, so, it's a small
kind of hobby.
It's not your full‐time job.
Is this your full‐time job?
It is my full‐time job.
I live on that.
It is?
You're starving
to death.
‐That's nothing.
‐That's why you're so skinny.
Oh, I can stretch money
really far. [ Chuckles ]
But, Schuyler,
if I'm gonna give you $100,000,
that's like
10 years of sales for you.
It's crazy.
You have to have a plan
to blow this thing up.
I want to hear
the plan.
The plan is to take
the pieces that I like the best
and especially something
like this thong,
which can be produced
very cheaply ‐‐
How many have you sold
of the thong?
Of the thongs?
10.
But I came out with them
this summer.
But wait.
These are basically
works of art
where you put your heart
and soul into it, right?
They are.
So why not charge more?
A lot of times,
when people see something
and it costs
more than they expect,
how they value it
goes way up.
How's he gonna make
a living, though?
You need to be able to make
a living off of this.
He really has to do it
in mass, Mark, because ‐‐
No.
No!
But he can't
get there, Lori.
How is he gonna
make money off ‐‐
The only way
this works is
if you sell that jumpsuit
for $1,000 or more.
And I can.
You should have no pieces
that cost less than $250.
If you're charging 60 bucks,
80 bucks,
it's just a piece
of clothing.
Be an artist.
Sell it as artwork.
You handmake each
and every one of these things.
It's a piece of art.
Sell it that way.
Oh, I agree. For my handmade
work, I totally agree.
You're still
not charging enough.
You don't have to sell a ton
of these when they're art.
You only
have to sell seven.
What are you doing,
Mark?
I'm out, but I think it's
a great opportunity for you.
But you just got to be an artist
that's proud of their work
and has some confidence that
it'll sell for a huge price.
♪♪
Schuyler, being a great artist
is not enough.
$37,000 is
really insignificant.
It's a start.
But for me
to give you $100,000,
you got to get this
to half a million.
You got to get
to $1 million.
And that is less art
and creative.
That's art and business.
There's no plan.
I'm out. I'm sorry.
Greiner:
As much as I love all of this,
I want to put
my heart and soul into it
and give the very best
that I can.
And, unfortunately, here,
I just don't think that this is,
like, right for me.
So I'm sorry.
I'm out.
John: Schuyler, I think
we've all pretty much agreed
in the same way.
I mean, you remind me
very much of myself.
I stood on a corner
and I sold $800 worth of hats,
and I realized
at that point,
"I will never work
for anybody, ever again
for the rest of my life."
But it took me 10 years
to figure it out from that day.
I just don't think
you have it figured out yet,
but you will never work
for anybody
for the rest of your life.
But right now, it's too early.
I'm out.
Schuyler, you had
all the components
that you need
on "Shark Tank" ‐‐
a brilliant idea,
the face of it.
Missing is
a person telling me,
"Look, Schuyler's
doing all this.
Meanwhile, I'm back in India.
I've got logistics.
I've got distribution.
I'm dealing with the retailers
we're gonna work with."
You need that partner,
whoever it is.
They're not there.
I would love to give you
$100,000.
I would love
to give you more.
I mean, this thing ‐‐
Greiner: Do it.
You can.
Do it. Do it.
I'm not going to,
because it's un‐investable.
‐Do it.
‐It's un‐investable.
[ Chanting "Do it" ]
That's my guy over there.
That's my guy, in the corner.
‐Thank you, guys. Thank you.
‐Do it! Do it!
O'Leary: But there's ‐‐
You know, I am an investor,
and I got to get it back.
I'm just frustrated,
and I'm sorry to say I'm out,
but you're one hell of a guy,
Lord Von Schmitt.
‐Thanks, guys.
‐Go in peace.
‐Congrats, Schuyler. Congrats.
Your words mean a lot to me.
They really do.
Alright, come on, guys.
Let's boogie on out of here.
‐Boogie on.
‐Thanks, guys.
[ Laughter ]
Ellers: The piece of advice
that I took away from that
was that I am selling myself
too cheap
and that if I'm an artist
and I have this charisma,
then I need to sell myself
for more.
And that was great
to hear it from them.
That gave me the power
to do it myself.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank
is a product designed to promote
dads bonding with their babies.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks!
My name is Nick Baker,
from Los Angeles, California,
and I am currently seeking
$100,000 for a 20% investment
in my company, DadWare.
Now, Sharks,
I have revolutionized
the way fathers ‐‐
yes, fathers ‐‐
bring their children
into the world,
and it all started with
the birth of my daughter, Eva.
My wife, Dawn, was in labor
for 36 long, relatively
uneventful hours.
‐Oy!
‐Wow.
And then Eva decided
to make her debut,
and it was mass hysteria!
Machines were beeping,
scalpels were slicing,
and Dawns were screaming!
And I just wanted
to get out of the way.
But when the doctor went
to put Eva on Dawn's chest
for the critical skin‐to‐skin
bonding immediately after birth,
Dawn was in too much pain.
So, what's a new dad to do
but jump into the greatest role
he's ever played, of course?!
That of
listen‐to‐the‐doctor dad!
I ripped off my shirt...
[ Laughter ]
...I took that baby...
and I put that baby
on my chest.
The doctor stopped.
The nurses were in awe.
A dad had finally listened!
[ Laughter ]
Now, over the next
couple of months,
I came to find out how special
the skin‐to‐skin
bonding thing really was.
I also found out that
not a whole lot of dads do it.
And because
I'm kind of jacked like a keg
and not ripped like Robert
over there...
[ Laughter ]
...and because dads need
a reminder to do the
skin‐to‐skin bonding at home,
I invented
the DadWare Bondaroo...
...a shirt that opens
for easy, convenient...
skin‐to‐skin bonding...
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
...at home or in the hospital
with your brand‐new baby.
[ Laughs ]
Aww.
So...
[ Laughter ]
No! No! No!
[ Laughter continues ]
Please don't do that at home
with your baby.
[ Laughs ]
So, sharks, I don't have
a business degree.
I don't have
some crazy MBA.
What I do have is
an incredible work ethic
in a company that I built
from the ground up
and a product that,
frankly,
I think makes the world
a better place.
Sharks,
I'm talking about investment
in our fathers and our children,
and what could be better
than that?
Sometimes, we get bad theater.
That was good theater.
‐Well, thank you.
‐Very good.
‐Yeah, that was very good.
I think you should have
a comedy routine.
I think I was
a former comedian and actor,
and that's one of the reasons
that I'm standing here.
Were you?
Would you like to see
the shirts?
'Cause that's a thing
we should do, right?
‐[ Laughing ] Sure.
‐I mean, we could just do that.
‐We're all about you.
‐We're into me. That's good.
That's good,
but hold on.
I forgot all about
the product, yeah.
Here you go.
Thank you.
Here you are.
‐Here you are, sir.
‐Thank you, Nick.
‐Brave man. Thank you.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Thanks, Nick. Good job.
‐Thank you very much.
So, Nick,
were you a comedian?
Yes.
I came to Los Angeles
about nine years ago
to be an actor
and a comedian,
and then about four years ago,
I had my baby,
and a 40‐year‐old waiter
isn't that cute.
I didn't feel like being poor
and living in L. A.
and that lifestyle of constantly
getting the next job.
And so I was like,
"Let's find a way out of this."
When did you have
the idea?
Four years ago?
Yeah. Yeah.
So, I had my baby.
I mean, that story's true.
I mean, I really did ‐‐
Like, Dawn was in so much pain.
That's why I took the baby
on the chest,
and then when I realized
how important it was
that we did it ‐‐
like, literally, the nurses
and doctors came up to me,
and they were shocked.
And I was like, "So,
you're telling me that
dads don't do this?"
Well, then I do research.
We really have to do this
with our kids.
It bonds us to our kids.
Now I have really refined
the product
to the point
where I'm super happy with it,
and I've also got my price down
in the United States.
What's it sell for?
I sell it for $39.99.
‐And what do you make it for?
‐What does it cost you?
$9.04 in
downtown Los Angeles.
That's a really
great price.
Making it in L. A.?
Mm‐hmm.
And how many
have you sold?
I have sold $200,000 worth
in the last ‐‐
‐Yeah, baby.
‐Wow.
‐Good for you.
‐That's really good.
And how are you getting
that message out?
Okay, that really
surprises me.
Where do you reach
that father?
I did not think
you were gonna say that.
You sold $200,000?
In the last year?
No. No. No. No.
How long?
Okay, so, I really started
selling November of 2016.
All the way up to 2017
of September,
we did, like, maybe $10,000.
Then from September 2017
to 2018, $71,000,
and then from September 2018
to 2019, $110,000.
Nick, what are you gonna do
with the $100,000?
Well, the first thing
is inventory.
Is that really
your problem?
Well, it's part of it.
Do you have orders
that you haven't filled?
No. I mean, I ‐‐
Then why do you need
inventory?
Because I've always been
struggling with it.
And you're running
this business 100%?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is all I do.
Is anybody helping you?
How are you making
a living?
So, over the last year,
I've kind of been hemorrhaging
money on my credit cards,
but now this money is ‐‐
the business is able
to pay me something now.
I mean, it can pay me, like,
Good for you.
a few thousand dollars a month
to keep our head above water.
So, Nick, you found
this very niche product.
I get it.
It's amazing.
And it's ‐‐
Thanks.
And now, you know,
you have to find your customer.
But this is not a product
that appeals to me in any way
'cause I'm not gonna have
any skin bonding with kids.
[ Laughs ]
So, look, I wish you the best,
but I'm not your Shark. I'm out.
Thank you so much, Kevin.
I appreciate that.
I tell you, Nick,
I'm fascinated
how you have
that amount of sales,
'cause you have a customer
that literally has one week
or whatever the case is
to have this experience.
And also, they can do it
various other ways ‐‐
you know, just laying at home
with the baby.
I think you'll keep
doing well with it
because you're the person
in the space,
but it's not a business
that I can invest in.
I'm out.
[ Chuckling ] Okay.
Yeah, Nick,
along the same lines,
look, what you've
accomplished is great.
The challenge is,
as you know,
there's just not one accelerant
that you can put on it, right?
It's hard. There's not,
like, some advertising routine
or some big marketing program
that you can do
that all of a sudden,
it's gonna blow it up, you know?
I just don't know
how I would scale it.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Really?
Really.
Nick, I really respect
the hustle.
But the timeframe to get
that customer is so small.
There's so many other ways
to do it.
I mean, power to you that you've
actually been able to do this,
but I can't connect the dots
going forward.
I ‐‐
I'm out.
Thank you.
But there's still Lori,
the Sharkette.
[ Chuckles ]
It's a very niche market ‐‐
like, just so small.
I find that it would be really
difficult for it to blow up.
But on the opposite side
of this,
all it takes
is one idea, right?
Which you have.
And this is a good idea.
And you can keep going
with this, and you can do more.
Right. Well ‐‐
I just don't find that it's
the right investment for me.
So I'm sorry ‐‐
I'm out.
Thank you, Nick.
It was a heck of a story.
‐Good luck, Nick.
‐Good luck to you.
‐Thanks so much, Sharks.
‐Congrats.
"Congrats."
How would he have found me
to market this product?
That's right, Daymond.
It's a big issue, acquiring
the customer at the right time.
And by the way, Mark,
I'm surprised you didn't think
about the Mavs using this.
This could've been
huge marketing for Mavs.
Dad with Mavs.
What do you think?
[ Laughter ]
"Dads with Mavs."
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a solution for one of
childhood's messiest problems.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
We're the Halls.
I'm Colt.
And I'm Stacy.
We live in Exeter, Missouri,
and we're seeking $50,000
in exchange for 15%
of our company, Potty Safe.
Sharks, we all know parenthood
is full of rewarding
and trying times.
And one of those
most trying times is...
Schew‐whee!
Potty training.
That's right, Sharks,
when potty‐training
our little ones,
we turn to the potty chair
to teach them
the dos and the don'ts.
But what happens
when your little ones
become overachievers?
They either try to dump it
all by themselves...
‐Oh!
‐Ew!
Or, worse,
they try to wear it as a hat.
[ Laughs ]
We're the ones left cleaning up
those nasty spills
all over our kiddos,
the floor,
or wherever else they decide
to leave their mark.
That's why we decided
to create a no‐mess,
less‐stress approach
to potty training.
Have no fear!
Potty Safe is here!
That's right, we're the first
and only potty‐training chair
to feature
a child‐proof latch.
Simply press in
on the child‐proof latch
on each side to remove
the waste bowl from the base.
Simple as that,
and then safely discard
of those wonderful
accomplishments.
To secure it
back into position,
just snap it back down
into the base.
Now, Sharks, we all know you
have little ones in your lives.
So who's ready to eliminate
that stress?
When it comes to
all that mess with a...
Potty Safe.     Potty Safe.
[ Chuckles ]
We have some samples
for you,
but first, we'll let him
get all dried up.
[ Chuckles ]
You can have mine,
Daymond.
Thank you.
Mr. Wonderful.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Uh‐huh. And Mark.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
Herjavec: Stacy, I have
16‐month‐old twins,
and I'm a little disturbed
by your presentation.
Yeah. And, you know, double
potty duty means double messes.
Wow.
Okay, so the child wants to take
their accomplishment
and put it in the toilet
themselves?
Yes, right,
'cause they see ‐‐
That happens a lot?
Yes, it does.
The child sees you
dump the potty,
and they want to help
dump the potty.
And they even like to
bring it to you and be
like, "Look what I did!"
‐Really?
‐Yes.
What age does this happen at
besides Robert?
[ Laughter ]
Well, that's actually
how we came up with it ‐‐
potty‐training
our daughter.
She was about 18 months,
2 years.
So right at where Robert's
twins are right now.
Oh, my gosh.
I have a lot of travel
coming up.
Yes, so you definitely
need this.
So, you created this?
You came up with the concept
and the idea?
Yes, uh‐huh.
I looked high and low
for a child‐proof
potty‐training chair,
and when I couldn't find it,
I thought,
"Okay, I'll just go buy
some supplies."
And then I handed the potty
and all those to my cowboy here,
you know, 'cause he can
fabricate anything.
What's your background?
Yeah,
what's your background?
Colt:
I just grew up on a farm.
I'm a fabricator, welder.
So, what was the process
to get from your first concept
to prototype
to this, which looks great?
Well, he fabricated it
on our kitchen island.
So we had some drills
in there going,
and we finished potty‐training
our daughter with our prototype,
and we didn't have
another issue again.
Wow.
And I said, "I think we really
have something here."
So I went online,
like, tried to see if there was
a patent out there,
and when it came back,
I thought, "Okay.
We need to go
for this."
And then we found out
how much tooling was.
Yeah.
And we're like,
"That's not something
to be taken lightly."
So we ended up
getting the funding
by mortgaging our house
for it.
It's how much
we believe in it.
Together: Wow.
How big a mortgage
did you get?
We got a revolving line
of credit against our house.
How much was it?
For $140,000,
but we invested...
Hoo.
...$152,000 total.
So, why doesn't the kid
just pick up the whole thing?
That's a great question.
To you and me,
we're grown adults,
so it does seem
very lightweight.
But to a toddler, they see you
pick up only the bowl...
It's pretty heavy
for a toddler to pick up.
But for a toddler,
it's big and bulky.
What were you doing before
you had this "aha" moment?
So, I grew up on a dairy farm,
and I ended up going to college.
Where'd you go
to college?
[ Voice breaking ] Um...
It's okay.
Ohh.
So, I went to Missouri
Southern State University.
Um, my dad wanted to make sure
I went to college
to have a better chance.
[ Sniffles ]
Anyway, so, I got my degree
in accounting,
and I joined
corporate America.
And my daughter at that time
basically only wanted Daddy.
Oh.
And, um, I left
corporate America
and got, like,
just a less‐stress job.
And it actually
worked out great,
'cause that was the time
we started to develop this.
And I just thought,
"You know what?
If I'm gonna work
this hard,
I might as well
work this hard for myself
and appreciate myself,"
so...
Which is great.
I hated to leave it,
but I'm like,
"That's what I spent
so many years going to school.
That's what my parents
paid for."
They came from a hard spot,
and they worked so hard.
It just gets me every time.
And they are
very proud of us.
But here you are
in the Shark Tank.
Let's focus on this product.
Okay. Yes.
What's the game plan
for world potty domination?
So, we have been actually
in talks with big‐box retailers.
We had a meeting with Walmart
just in June.
Wow.
Did they like the product?
Yes, they did.
We're in touch with them.
My daughter was potty‐trained
at 14 months.
What?!
Yeah.
She was potty‐trained ‐‐
So how long did it take?
It took literally,
like, a week.
That's 'cause
she's a genius.
Well, no, that's like ‐‐
we gave her M&Ms every time.
That's exactly what I did.
I gave Jake M&Ms.
Right, yeah.
Exactly. So I didn't know that
this problem really existed.
I just ‐‐
is this a big enough problem?
Yeah.
And you know what?
Maybe we can find that out
by you telling us sales or ‐‐
Yeah, so ‐‐
Well, before you
get into total sales,
what's your cost to make, and
what do you sell each one for?
Then tell us
your total sales.
Yeah.
We have $6.50 in each unit,
and they retail for $28.95.
And where are you
selling them now?
On our website.
Uh‐huh.
And last month
we just launched on Amazon,
and it's doing really well.
What do you think
you'll do next month,
all‐in, all the channels?
For the rest of the year,
we're estimating $15,000.
And what have you done
for the year so far?
So, the entire year,
we've sold $2,000,
but that's 'cause we didn't have
money to go toward marketing.
So you'll do $17,000 this year?
$17,000?
Yeah.
The sales worry me.
Because my experience
with products like this
that really fit a niche,
that mommies
or people like that love,
is they kind of go boom
a little bit.
So I'm surprised that
you're not getting more uplift.
Is it because the market for it
just isn't that big?
No, I think the market
is that big for it,
because just in
the last two months,
we've seen
such an increase in sales.
How much did you sell
last month?
Last month, we had
about $200 in sales.
And the month before that?
The same.
And there are more sales,
of course, on the way
with the retail
and the big‐box stores.
Hopefully.
Yes.
I love your story,
and I love how you guys
worked this product out.
I just ‐‐ I don't really know
anything about this space.
I just wouldn't be
of value to you, so I'm out.
Alright. Thank you.
Stacy, I love the ingenuity
and how practical you guys are.
And I don't want to
discourage you,
but I just think
it's small.
I'll definitely buy it,
because, apparently, I need one.
[ Laughing ] Yeah.
Or two, in my case.
Two. Two.
Yeah. I'm out.
Thank you.
Yeah, guys, to give you $50,000
isn't a lot of money from us.
It's a lot to you, obviously,
and it can be very impactful,
but it's hard, really,
to partner at that level.
I wish I could just say
I'm all‐in,
but I can't be,
so for those reasons, I'm out.
Alright. Thank you.
Thank you.
There's a huge issue here.
It's the elephant
in the room.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
And Kevin has an issue
with Colt and Stacy's
potty‐training seat, Potty Safe.
It's the elephant
in the room.
You haven't proven there's
any demand for this product.
It's a tough one.
Nobody in America wants
to see you fail with this.
Me either.
But it's not clear
what the path is.
I wish you the best.
I really do, but I'm out.
Lori?
[ Chuckles ]
Well, I think you did
an amazing job of it,
but I do feel that this
is gonna be a tough journey.
I just don't feel
it's investable for me today,
and I'm sorry, but I'm out.
That's alright.
Alright, well,
thank you for your time.
Thank you, guys.
Herjavec: Yeah.
Alright.
Good luck, guys.
You can do this.
Thanks.
No, wait. You know what?
Come back.
Come back. Come back.
My Squatty Potty company ‐‐
it was a little stool
that helps you poop.
[ Laughter ]
And everybody laughed at it.
Yeah.
But that little stool ‐‐
we are seriously
at $160 million in sales,
I think.
Maybe I could have them
look at this ‐‐
because we have a lot
of brand extensions ‐‐
and see if there's something
that we can do together.
Um...
So I'll do $50,000
for...
20%.
You got a deal.
Okay. Yay!
‐Good job, Lori.
‐Whoo!
That is the Shark
with the heart.
Yeah.
‐There you go, Lori. Good job.
‐Thank you so much. Thank you.
‐That's awesome.
‐I am so happy for you guys.
Greiner: Alright,
we're gonna make this work.
Congrats, guys. Good job.
Oh, my gosh.
We did it!
[ Laughs ]
[ Crying ]
Oh, my God,
did that just happen?
[ Chuckling ]
Did that just happen?
My parents
are just very hardworking,
and, you know, they've been
such role models, too.
Bounced back. You know,
they had some hard times.
And to watch them work
their butts off and come back,
I just, you know,
want to make them proud.
♪♪